hello near thorion the rest of the
youtube community i did this is the part
of your complaints about that we need to
develop other measures of say human
progress or happiness whatever the GDP
is restricted that's true gross domestic
product as referred to you really
measures a lot of their stuff about
economic the new economy if you take
that innovation and things like that the
service act isn't adequately reflecting
that and if you broaden it further than
that we are trying to develop the UN
system and others much broader index
there is probably for example by the
UNDP at the united nations development
program every year the Human Development
Index where one tries to look at how
country's progress and cause a very
broad range of different things be that
health or social indicators are
environmental indicators I don't think
happiness is really we haven't found a
way of measuring happiness but much
broader measurements of the way which
society's progress that's called for and
that's receptive than other way